okay so jupiter's legacy deserves a big
breakdown
and there's a lot to explain about its
twist ending the show is based on the
graphic novel series of the same name by
mark miller
and in all honesty it's one of the best
comic book runs i've ever read
the new season of the netflix show
adapts roughly the first two and a half
issues of it
and because of this there's a lot left
out in terms of the overall arc
throughout this video we're going to be
discussing the show's ending
where things could be going in the
future and how the series changed things
from the original graphic novels
without the way welcome to the heavy
spoilers show i'm your host paul
now let's get into our ending explained
of jupiter's legacy
okay so the story centers around sheldon
sampson a wealthy businessman who lost
everything after the stock market crash
in 1929
after his father ended his own life
sheldon started to be haunted by visions
of him
and a mysterious island after a lot of
back and forth
sheldon traveled to this island with
members of his family and friends one of
which was last seen doing a spread for
tony stark
big spread now upon arriving there they
came across an
alien doorway that took them to what i
think might be jupiter
although it could be uranus upon
returning from space
they all look like they've taken
asteroids and
thus started the jupiter's legacy though
i think saturn
would have had a nice ring to it hey ba
bom cha now though this arc takes place
roughly across six pages in the source
material the series expands it into a
massive episode spanning storyline
that adds a lot of weight to why the
characters go on the arcs that they do
the season jumps back and forth between
two time periods
with the first one being the origin
story and the latter being them in their
winter years
as they try and comprehend the way that
the world is as a superhero group called
the union
they stood for truth justice and the
american way
sheldon or rather the utopian forced
each member to live by a code that meant
they wouldn't get involved in politics
or ever take a life whether this is
still relevant today
is something that he and the rest of the
group wrestle with and
it becomes a big driving force in the
series now sheldon viewed the world as
very much being black and white but with
things devolving into shades of grey
an insurrection starts up within the
group led by his brother walter
walter possesses psychic powers and
views himself as someone who could have
really changed humanity on a global
scale instead of being relegated to
simply stopping bank robbers because his
brother said so
walter was never the favorite and it's
clear that he harbours a lot of
resentment to being stuck in his shadow
the season is very much about him
putting the pieces in place to create an
uprising against him
and come the end of the show we discover
that he created a clone of a
supervillain called black star
which he used as a weapon after almost
wiping out the union
sheldon sun brandon stepped in to save
the day and he crossed
the line by killing black star in order
to save his father
this disappointed his dad to some degree
as he would have rather died than have
the code broken
and walter's plan is very much about
making brandon realise that his dad's
view of the world is outdated
and that he has to go he wants to push
brandon away from his father
by creating a bad atmosphere between
them which we witness throughout the
series i promise that's the last
terrible space pun i'll do
and that's pretty much walter's plan in
a nutshell and he views humanity as
being unable to look after itself
thus he wants to remove the utopian from
power so that he can come in and take
over the planet
now though this series itself doesn't
tackle this i think we should look to
the backstory in the comics to explain
some of the things going on here
you see in 1929 walter could have
actually saved the family business
and thus his father's life however he
was talked down from doing what he
thought was right by his brother and
father
and because of this he harbors a lot of
resentment walter even drops the line
no one knows what they're doing except
for me showcasing that he believes he
must take control
because of the recession and politics
the modern world is facing a similar
dilemma to what it was all the way back
in 29
and thus he believes that if he's
ignored again dire consequences will
follow
however there comes a ray of hope in sky
fox
the mortal enemy of walter who appears
at one point in the series
sky fox is a very important character in
the show
and when we look at the comics the pair
have a long-standing rivalry
now time codes are linked below if you
want to skip ahead to a certain section
but i feel the best way to talk about
the ending is to first discuss the
history of the union
then what happens after the ending with
sheldon and brandon and the big
character arc that chloe goes on
now the prequel story jupiter's circle
reveals that after they gained their
powers
the group initially tried to do good but
they found that politics
always got in the way it's revealed that
blue bolt was actually gay
and that photographs of him were
secretly taken by the fbi
blackmailed by j edgar hoover he almost
gave up the names of the group but
attempted to take his own life instead
hoover backed off after blue bolt
blackmailed him with evidence of his own
gay relationship
and thus the union decided to stay away
from politics completely
all whilst abiding by their own rules
george aka sky
fox was commissioned to build a supermax
prison that we see throughout the series
but tensions between him and walter grew
even stronger
due to the former always rubbing him the
wrong way george broke up with his
girlfriend sonny who almost
immediately started dating walter and
this drove george crazy
he believed that walter was actually
using his superpowers to psychically
make her fall in love with him
and though he could never prove it
george ended up leaving the union over
it
george stopped being a superhero but one
day he did have an epiphany
george believed that the alien
technology hadn't been given to them to
keep the world the same
as they'd once thought rather he
believed that they were blessed with
these incredible abilities
in order to change it whereas sheldon
thought that they should stay removed
from the bigger things
george believed that they had to get
involved to make things better on a
bigger scale
thus he attended the 1965 la riots
and forced the police to stand down when
vietnam happened he kidnapped the vice
president
and held him to ransom turning the tide
of what he viewed as an unjust war
sky fox was labeled the super villain
but when the criminal hobbs a version of
which we meet in the series
stripped the union of their powers and
tossed them into a dark matter doorway
he stepped in to save the day sky fox
was accepted back into the union
but walter revealed to him that he
actually did use his mind tricks on
sunny
and this sent george off the deep end
the bear had a battle that almost
destroyed an entire city
and sheldon stepped in in order to break
them up sky fox tried to tell sheldon
that walter had been mind controlling
sunny
but it ultimately fell on deaf ears and
the utopian believed his brother over
his friend
in episode 8 sky fox actually hints
towards this battle
and discusses how the last time he saw
walter that the union beat him to a pulp
sky fox was arrested and put in the
supermax but saying as he built it he
was able to escape
and the villain wasn't seen again now
over the years though walter came to
hate george
he realized that he was right and that
the union couldn't stay stuck in the
past
thus he enacted this uprising that we
see play out in the series
and the comics actually differ slightly
from the season as in those there was no
clone of black star
though the series pulls the fight
between the union and the villain
directly from the pages and panels of
the work
they do deviate heavily in the comics
walter entered his mind
much like how we see in the beach scene
however he simply held him in place
whilst the union beat him on the outside
brandon doesn't even show up for this
fight in the comics
and though his friends are there they
aren't killed instead what drives a
wedge between him and his father
happens when brannon tries to carry a
ferry across the sky
that he almost drops due to his
drunkenness his father saves the day
but berates him and makes him feel
completely useless
this is when walter sinks his claws in
and brandon becomes
angry that his father neglected him and
his sister chloe when they were younger
now from this point onwards we're gonna
be doing some big spoilers from the
comics
and whilst they might change things up
in the series i do think that the plot
will probably go this way
also if you're enjoying this video then
please hit the thumbs up button
and make sure you subscribe for
breakdowns like this each and every day
okay so because walter can't beat
sheldon himself he convinces brandon
that
he has to be the one to do it he says
that when he kills sheldon
he will take his place and due to the
inferiority complex he's developed by
the fact his father told him he wasn't
good enough
this tactic works after faking an attack
the utopian is ambushed by several
superheroes
who walter has convinced to join his
side and they all stand around and beat
him
similar how julius caesar was betrayed
by those closest to him
the ultimate betrayal comes in when
brandon steps forth
and murders his father seemingly taking
his place
however walter asks what's the first
thing you want to do to help your fellow
man
and brandon's reply is actually i'm not
entirely sure
what do you think uncle walter it's a
moment that still gives me goosebumps to
this day
and walter is of course now in control
using brandon as a weapon to take over
the world
now elsewhere we also watch as chloe
returns home after learning she's
pregnant with hutch's child
her mother is killed by walter in front
of her and just before
she's about to be murdered too she is
saved by hutch
the pair are forced to go on the run and
their child jason becomes a new
superhero
now the latter part of the work very
much focuses on him
walter rules over the entire planet and
the second graphic novel sees the
rebellion of the quote-unquote
supervillains
as they try and attempt to stop sheldon
and walter it's an
absolutely incredible story and i
definitely recommend that you check it
out if you haven't already
i will be doing a full comic book
breakdown on it at some point
but those are the main direction that
things are going in
now as i touched on earlier the series
very much expands upon things
and it is possible that it won't go in
this direction if you haven't read the
work then you'll be surprised at how
short the arc that happens in the show
happens in the comics i actually think
it's probably only about
40 pages or so and it flies by when
you're reading it
depending on how long this story goes on
for in the show
could massively alter the events and the
way that things happen
and it is possible that they take things
in a totally new direction
why i think this may be the case is
because walter kills his own daughter
whereas in the source material she
actually ends up working with him
i think that for season two walter may
weaponize her death
and potentially frame skyfox for it
making it so that the code seems even
more useless
this will have bran in question whether
his dad is really doing the right
thing and he will likely go back and
forth over what to do with his father
now not only is the cloning of black
star pinning on skyfox
then walter's daughter's murder could be
too and it may cause a worldwide manhunt
for him
in the comics barnabas wolfe a character
that we meet briefly in the show
is tasked with tracking down rogue
superhumans i think that he might be put
on the job
he's very much walter and brandon's
handyman so do
expect to see a lot more of him although
i don't think that jason
will be introduced in the next season i
do think that chloe's pregnancy will be
announced
this was the thing that made her really
change her ways
and after herch had been abandoned by
his dad skyfox
he decided that he would be there for
his son overall there is quite a lot to
like in the series
and though it didn't advance the plot as
much as i was expecting
i did quite enjoy it now sadly knowing
all that i know about the graphic novel
may have shown the show in an inferior
light the stuff we tackle here is very
much
just the intro stuff to set up this
story and it's not really until
walter starts to enact his plan that
everything falls into place
now i think that people who don't know
what's going on in the comics
might just view this as a rather
run-of-the-mill superhero show
that doesn't quite do anything new
though i know they'd be wrong
it's difficult to argue against that
without talking about the work
and going off just the show as a whole i
know that when it's presented on its own
it might not blow everyone's socks off
however the pieces are all there and
if you love the graphic novel series
then i think there is definitely a lot
to fall in love with
certain moments such as the shark
infested water scene that's ripped
straight out of the comics
and it does a very good job of bringing
the pages to the screen
now i think that at points this felt
very middle of the road
i know there is a lot coming down the
line i kind of wish they'd done more
than eight episodes and potentially
ended it with the big death in the
comics
currently i am struggling whether to
recommend this to people
or just saying to them wait until season
2 drops
so you have more of the plot but either
way you know it is worth sticking around
for
now one of the things that the series
excels at is that it gives
far more character development than we
got in the comics you really see the mad
and insane journey that sheldon goes on
and the doubt that arises from those
around him driving their motives to
question him once more
josh does a great job of portraying a
road weary superman
and both he and ben daniels feel like
perfect casting in their roles
though i feel like the old people make
up was a bit hit and miss
this is still a pretty solid first entry
in a show that netflix are referring to
his volumes
the acting was great and this is
definitely something i think you could
probably put on in the background
just to keep you entertained for a
couple of hours however as a fan i am
desperate to see the rest of the ark
play out
and i hope that we get it sooner rather
than later all in all jupiter's legacy
vol 1 was a good first chapter
and i am hyped to see what's next our
final score is a seven out of ten
but obviously i'd love to see if people
disagree or agree with me
i can see a lot of people loving it and
did i not have such a big attachment to
the original work
then it would probably score higher i do
think that when it's all out i'll look
back on the series in a higher regard
but for the meantime as it is that's
where i come down on it
now there's lots to talk about so get
typing and if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of the finale of invincible
which will be linked on screen right now
that's another massive superhero show
that has a lot of things going on in it
so definitely check it out right after
this if not then thank you for sitting
through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace